freha de salut bonjour au sida oui
bonjour et merci d'être heures en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors les
talibans un sont aujourd'hui bien
installé au pouvoir ils ont présenté
leur gouvernement avec le retour
finalement peut-on craindre que
l'afghanistan ne redevienne un repère
pour les djihadistes
oui ou relativement oui mais si les
talibans ont lancé un défi voilà notre
gouvernement parce que se comportent
comme des vainqueurs moi je vois leurs
discours à travers la chaîne al jazira
la chaîne qatariote al-jazira qui a la
foi aux américains et néo pro talibans
parce qu'il est le paradoxe donc qu'ils
se comportent comme des vainqueurs
n'oublions pas on avait laissé unis
d'amérique on a vaincu l'otan on a vécu
toutes ses forces alors on va imposer
notre volonté aussi c'est la revanche et
ethniques la revanche des pêches tout
parce qu'on néglige dans l'immédiat que
c'est un tout le vrai conflit en
afghanistan les vrais conflits entre la
majorité pachtoune soutenus par le
pakistan et d'autres minorités comme la
minorité tadjike ou le feu ahmad shah
massoud au namm minoré t hasard les
chiites pour gagner donc c'est la
victoire des pachtouns la victoire de
l'intégrisme la victoire de à libon et
se comportent comme des victorieux mais
pas sonore pour le moment je n'étais pas
trop étonné de le dire que la chine a
salué ce gouvernement la chine qu'il a
grimpé au point juin a salué ce
gouvernement donc peut-être parce que
les talibans actuellement dans un
carrefour peut-être les choix
stratégiques
stratégiques vont vers la chine au lieu
de l'occident mais savent bien les
talibans qui sont dans une position de
force en position de négociation donc
ils demandent de plus en plus en
occident en même temps les eaux les
alternatives d'une alternative
évidemment c'est la chine le pakistan
justement comment est-ce que aujourd'hui
l'occident doit être celle traitée
dialoguer avec avec les talibans comme
une force politique
l'occident a perdu la guerre il faut le
savoir l'occident a perdu la guerre de
gamme histoire par exemple temps est là
donc il est allé bon les traîtres camp
des perdants à mon avis aussi à l'union
européenne peut parler toujours des
sanctions économiques mais à mon avis
aussi le programmiste on est très très
loin de sanctions économiques pourquoi
parce qu'il a un voisin très très
puissant au plan économique et la chine
et la chine apparemment est en train de
se tenir le talent est bon aujourd'hui
aussi elle a le soutien de pakistan
c'est un pays qui compte environ 15
millions d'habitants donc il n'a pas
vraiment besoin d'un technologies
occidentales comme diront non là au plan
local et régional
il pourrait satisfaire de ce qu'est un
chinois et citoyen pakistanais donc
l'occident a perdu 7 les guerres en
afghanistan et je l'avouer tout de même
il reste une certaine poches de
résistance afghane qui est très présente
notamment dans la région du panjshir on
sait que le fils du célèbre commandant
massoud a appelé un soulèvement national
contre les talibans est-ce que voilà
cette résistance peut encore
se retrouver faire barrière face à cet
aliment est peut-être renverser les
talibans
il faut lire cette résistance autrement
parce que comme j'ai dit les médias
citons tout parle toujours d'un conflit
radiologie les intégristes les
intéristes et laïque non c'est pas si
c'est un conflit ethnique ahmad shah
massoud
cc c'est un tragique donc l'état gic ne
veulent pas la domination des pachtouns
en tant que minorité doivent résister
pas uniquement sur le plan idéologique
mais surtout sur le plan ethnique et les
talibans sont soutenus par évidemment
sont soutenus par l'ethnie pachtoune et
par le pakistan où il ya une
prolongation donc ce conflit ethnique je
parle pas maintenant dans le conflit et
biologie va continuer peut-être les
hasards aussi chine vont continuer à
lutter contre les talibans autrement dit
vont continuer à lutter contre la
domination des bâches tout vandalisme je
voudrais également que l'on parle un
petit peu de l'avenir du peuple afghan
on voit qu'aujourd'hui les femmes
risquent d'être complètement mises de
côté aucune femme n'est dans le
gouvernement elles sont interdites de
faire du sport si elles doivent aller
étudier elles devront porter le niqab
finalement c'est un retour en arrière
pour des femmes qui se sont émancipés
pendant une certaine période
oui évidemment sur tous les ans ils
auraient importé ministère qui s'appelle
me josy mais mystère des morses ça veut
dire quand on voit il faut qu'il n'est
pas voilée on peut la frappe est dans la
rue on peut interpeller la même chose m
couple il faut demander un acte de
mariage ainsi de suite mais mais cette
organisation a existé toujours l'arabie
saoudite l'arabie saoudite c'était un
pays protégés par l'occident digel le le
concept de ce ministère de maurs vient
de la revit sans doute parce que les
théologies aussi de talent et peut
espérer deux avisos saoudien donc il ya
aussi un double discours en occident
quant à pays on a des bons rapports
économiques avec les looney on peut le
havre et on le protège on peut ne pas
voir c'est ce côté noir la met puisqu'il
s'agit de l'afghanistan puisqu'on a
perdu aussi la guerre on va parler de
ces détails mais évidemment on est face
à un mouvement intégriste totalement
intégristes on va pas avoir des cadeaux
de ce mode mata crise malgré un discours
un peu réconciliant du plu mais on va
voir ses 29 et vont impliquer leur chair
et à leur façon évidemment comme comme
le voit la charia parce qu'il ya
plusieurs interprétations de la charia
islamique et surtout avec une négligence
totale de l'occident il voit en occident
il va il faut que je vois que les
occidentaux ont perdu la guerre sur leur
sol et mais en fait non ali peut-être
probablement c'est la chine merci
beaucoup en tout cas en rien de celui
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes expert du monde
arabe et directeur du centre arabe de
recherches et des analyses politiques et
sociales